uh snox for uh p and batch np from lwe
it should warn you front that lwa is not
going to show up anywhere in the talk so
the talk is really about snarks from
some standard assumptions right okay
uh so the main object we are interested
in is a form of non-interactive argument
where the prover and verifier hold a
instance from some np language and the
prover wants to convince the verifier
that the statement is in this language
is true
we want the standard completeness and
soundness properties completeness says
that if x is true the verify should
accept and soundness says that if x is
false then the verifier should reject
and
in this talk we are interested in
computational soundness which is hence
which is why we are talking about
argument systems so soundness only holds
against uh ppt rulers
on their own these objects are fairly
easy to build right the prover can just
send a witness to the verifier so that
is not very interesting so usually we
equip non-interactive arguments with
some additional properties and the main
property that we are interested in is
succinctness which essentially requires
that the proof size and the verification
time should be much smaller than the
witness length uh here the
representation is for turing machine
modeling but the same intuition applies
so these objects also the way i modeled
it on the slide they are not really
possible uh in the in the plane model uh
so we usually equip the proven verify
with something extra uh in this talk we
are interested in
equipping them with a crs a common
reference string which ideally should be
from the uniform distribution but could
be structured as well
okay
so in this talk i am mainly going to
focus on one question um okay so i
skipped a slide uh sorry so let me first
try to convince you uh you know why we
care about uh these uh objects um
all these motivations are fairly obvious
uh first and foremost uh these objects
are fascinating to build mainly because
of this uh seemingly strange thing
that's requirement the fact that we can
achieve them is quite intriguing um
if you have watched you all stalk at a
previous times workshop you can see uh
hopefully you're convinced that there's
a strong interplay with theoretical
computer science here and as far as
applications are concerned uh you know
it's uh we all know about applications
of snacks to blockchains and uh
perhaps the the statement at the bottom
here is a little bit controversial to
some that uh uh snug especially when
equipped with zero knowledge are
probably now overtaken even fhe in
popularity if you go to uh you know a a
random meetup group uh in especially in
the bay area you are likely to hear
non-academics
excitedly talking about snogs even if
they don't really you know understand
the the details uh i've i've done that
so yeah you can take my word on it
okay so in this talk i'm mainly
interested in one question which is what
assumptions uh can we build snarks from
okay and the the talk is really you know
not going to focus unlike the last talk
it's not really going to focus on
concrete efficiency we are just
interested in in asymptotics and
most of the talk is going to focus on
the present right so in true spirit of
mindfulness uh but i will talk uh some
about the past and uh a little bit about
the the future directions as well
okay
[Music]
okay so let's talk uh talk about what we
knew uh about snogs
for np uh this is
um circa 2019 roughly
okay so we the perhaps the most famous
result is uh snarks warranty in the
random oracle model which we know from
the work of macaulay which essentially
takes a killian and then collapses it
using random oracles and we can
obviously instantiate it using some
concrete hash function like sha256 and
get heuristic security
the other very popular line of work is
to build snots from
knowledge or extractability assumptions
right and this is a really really long
line of work um
perhaps the
you know i stopped at 2016 if you look
at the works beyond that it's you know
many fold times in number and i should
say that many of these schemes are very
completely efficient they're implemented
used in practice and you know
the many startups emanating from this
line of work um
from a theoretical perspective you could
argue that it's perhaps a little bit
unsatisfactory um you know
for one the assumptions used here are
non-falsifiable in the sense of you know
moni's definition
if you think about the reduction as a
subroutine sorry as an algorithmic
construct then there is a missing
subroutine in that reduction right which
is the assumption uh that there exists a
small extractor right
and
you can also kind of think in a
different way that uh you know you are
building an extractor assuming an
extractor right if you draw an analogy
from the line of work in non-valuable uh
cryptography there also sometimes we we
have the scenario where you can assume
non-memberity of some weak form to build
non-valuability uh for stronger forms so
okay
so that's um
so this is what we knew so you know what
we are interested in is uh you know
using more standard assumptions
so there there is a big barrier which is
very well known the work of gentry and
wix showed that
if you want snacks for np
then with some caveats uh you know it's
uh it's going to be highly unlikely if
you want to build them from standard uh
slash falsifiable assumptions okay so
i'm going to ignore the caveats right
now and just uh go on believing that
this is the end of the story that it's
impossible from standard assumptions
i'll revisit this towards the end of the
talk okay
okay so now if we if we have this
impossibility and just treat it as an
unconditional impossibility result then
we are left with the sort of one natural
question which is can we build snarks
for subclasses of np some interesting
subclasses of np from standard
assumptions okay and this is what the
talk is going to mainly focus on and i'm
going to focus on two subclasses in
particular
the first is very natural polynomial
time computations
okay which is uh
which is essentially the scenario where
a client
you know
has delegated some computation to some
some server and the server wants to
convince him that he performs some
polynomial time computation correctly
and the verification time should be much
smaller than the time it takes to
compute
um and this object itself has many uh
you know many important applications
cryptography listed some of them here
the second class that i'm interested in
is snags for
batch np so this is a structured uh you
know version of np where the prover is
uh trying to prove let's say k instances
um
to the verifier and we want that the
proof size should be much smaller than
the total witness length which in this
case is k times the size of one witness
okay and the verification time should
also be correspondingly smaller except
that the verifier will have to read the
instances once but that's about it
okay do we have to prove that all of
them are yes
yes
so you can consider some generalizations
but for this topia i am interested in
and case all the instances are true okay
so
yeah it doesn't need to be it's just
generally yeah written more generally
but yeah
good
so batch np is itself a useful tool for
building other applications as well uh
in fact even before people looked at
snacks for batch np batch verification
for example was studied in the setting
of signature schemes and other
primitives
but you can use snarks for batch np to
also build aggregate signatures
okay so why am i talking about these two
particular classes uh well first and
foremost uh gentrifix lower bond doesn't
apply here
okay
at a technical level some connection
between these two subclasses was already
made in prior works of uh yales vicar
and justin and and some follow-up works
um in this talk i will show a more
formal connection and this will this was
also established in uh another work
recently
and uh one take away message uh should
be that uh snarks for batch np are sort
of a very good workhorse for building
other kind of snorks and you know other
other things so
that will be one message from this talk
okay so now if we focus on just these
two subclasses p and batch np then we
can look at what was already known in
this setting and there are sort of two
categories uh so one line of work very
interesting line of work uh
initiated in by krr
in 2013 was
looking at the the setting where the
verifier is holds a secret key for
verification so this is the setting
where along with the crs you sample some
secret verification key that is given to
the verifier so only that verifier can
verify proofs
and in this setting uh you know you can
actually build
such a succinct proof systems for p and
batch np
and even some other related classes
based on standard assumptions
but the the setting that i'm interested
in for this talk is uh the public
verification setting where there's no
secret verification key anyone can look
at the proof and verify
and here uh
essentially we were in two sort of
settings either you can use the
obfuscation style assumptions
obfuscation or even multiple maps
or some non-standard assumptions in
bilinear map settings but
but essentially so so i'm cheating a
little bit here standard assumptions if
you know
uh if if i o is from standard
assumptions then uh you know maybe maybe
this question comes with an asterisk but
let's let me redefine standard as
meaning uh lwe or bilinear maps just uh
something of that sort right okay so
this is the main question can we build
uh snarks for p and batch and p from uh
from standard assumption
okay so just a question about the model
adaptive soundness and then yeah so i
did not talk about
adaptive versus non-adductivity the
soundness will be adaptive for p it will
be fully adapted for batch np it will be
semi-adaptive which uh
um
maybe ask me again later and i'll point
you when i yeah i won't talk about the
exact adaptivity model but you can yeah
right good so for p it will be fully
adaptive and for batch np
it is essentially the the most
adaptivity you can hope for beyond which
uh it starts uh applying uh the the
gentrifix uh thing starts upland yeah
i know i know it's because of the known
transformations uh you know from prior
works that if you have fully adaptive uh
batch np
with the argument of knowledge property
which you know the world does achieve
then you can convert them to uh snarks
for adaptive smarts for uh
uh
this is something from uh um bhk uh uh
uh also uh start with the decimated
verified starts as you're saying it uh
that doesn't uh matter i mean they
showed this transformation in that
designated verifier setting but the same
thing applies in the public verification
setting as well so again i'm saying that
if you have snarks for batch np with
full adaptive soundness
and also an argument of knowledge uh
property then you can take that throw in
some additional machinery and you will
get snugs for np with adaptive soundness
which would
yeah which would violate uh i mean some
hash functions
you get it through the version and for
our results
no yeah then it doesn't happen
your subscription
again for the adaptivity that we defined
it's uh it makes sense but yeah you're
right i am a little cheating a little
bit here but yeah uh there are various
flavors of uh you know
but this one is not sufficient for the
implications that's true
extraction
more stuff for the future work right
you know i don't actually
i can try to reconstruct it
and
talk about two results uh both from the
same work which is that uh we can build
snarks for p from lwe uh the
the parameters are uh asymptotically
essentially what you would want right
everything is polylog in
in t so in the tutoring machine model um
and then uh for batch np also it's uh
essentially the parameters that you
would want uh later i will towards the
end of the talk i'll mention you know
even
stronger requirements potentially in
terms of future work but
yeah these are the the two results
okay
so let me then just jump uh to
background
and
the main sort of you know starting point
uh for these works and a lot of uh work
in cryptography in the recent years is
essentially uh looking at the revisiting
the future paradigm and then trying to
instantiate the random oracles in that
uh paradigm using concrete hash
functions okay so let me just recall uh
what is phmeir so it's essentially a
technique for around collapsing public
coin interactive protocols using random
oracle so if you start with let's say a
sigma protocol then you can apply the
future heuristic which says that
instead of the verified sampling a
random challenge uh interactively the
prover can just compute the random
challenge as applying the random oracle
on the first
round message so this is for three
rounds but the you can generalize it for
more on protocols
and now the approver can just compute
the entire transcript in one shot and
send it out and the verifier can check
for correctness
okay so this is can be proven sound in
the in the random oracle model
um
and now the the natural question is if
you want to obtain a result in the in
the standard model where by standard i
mean that let's say we use a crs and
then get rid of the random oracle
then we can already ask the question uh
you know can we instantiate this random
oracle with maybe some particular hash
function family
and we know that there are some negative
results in this direction so if you want
to apply this paradigm for general
arguments there are some
explicit uh counterexamples a bit
contrived and even in the setting of
proofs there are some partial negative
results
on the other hand there was a possible
route uh you know suggested in some
early works via this notion of uh
correlation interactable hash functions
and this is the the notion that i'm
going to talk about which is going to be
the central player in
in obtaining positive results
so let me define correlation in
tractable hash functions
so it's essentially a family of hash
functions key hash functions
which are associated with some function
class f
so i'm actually i should say i'm giving
a simplified uh definition where i'm
defining correlation in tractability
with a function uh class you can
generalize this relation uh this this
definition to hold for relations instead
of functions so again the idea is that
you know
we want
that any ppt adversary should fail in
the following in the following
experiment where you sample a key from
the you know from the from the key space
at random and then the prov the the ppt
adversary is supposed to output a
a value x such that when you apply a
hash
over when you compute the hash over this
value x what you what you obtain is
actually the output of f on x
and again and you want that the
probability that this happens is
negligible
again if you want to generalize it for
relations then what you would want is
that you know the probability that the
relation uh when it takes as input x and
h of uh hk of x uh you know it accepts
right
so this is the the notion of uh
correlation interactable hash functions
and
now suppose we have such uh hash
functions okay
then let's try to see how we can use
them to actually instantiate the random
oracle in this future
paradigm so now let's say we sample a
key for correlation and tractable hash
functions and i haven't defined what is
the function class f yet i will in a
moment
but let's say we sample a key from this
family of hash functions and that's a
part of the crs now which is given to
the approver in the verifier and now the
prover works as expected you know it
will just compute the challenge
as the hash of the first message and
then compute the response sends it to
the verifier the verifier can also
recompute the challenge and then just
check for the transcript correctness
okay
so the question is why is this sound
right
okay so here is the idea and again i'll
consider the simplified case where the
protocol that i'm starting with has
two special soundness which is basically
saying that if i give you two accepting
transcripts with the same first message
then you can extract a witness okay so
in other words what i'm asking is that
uh um for any uh alpha that is the first
message there is a unique uh beta that
can lead to an accepting gamma
okay so you can see that the special
soundness implies this property right
again when x is false right when the
statement is false then for any alpha
there is a unique beta on which
you can find there even exists an
accepting gamma okay
okay so now
i can define a function this mapping
from uh the first message of the
protocol that is alpha to this bad uh
beta right the bad challenge for which
there could exist an accepting
transcript
yes i'm calling this function as bad
function
and now
i'm going to basically consider
correlation interactable hash functions
which are correlation intractable for
these bad functions
and now if we look at this
transformation we can argue soundness
as follows so if a cheating prover does
output an accepting transcript right for
a false statement x then you can see
that uh first of all by definition
the the challenge beta is just the
output of the hash but at the same time
you know because uh you know the way we
define this bad function right we have
that beta is also the output of the bad
function applied on alpha right
so now you have that basically the
output of the hash is equal to the
output of the bad function on the same
alpha and this contradicts correlation
in fact ability
okay so this is how we get soundness
again this is for the simplified case
the idea can be generalized a little bit
uh i'm not going to get into too much
details of how some of the
generalization works it's uh
yeah there are some subtleties that show
up but uh for for the purpose of the
illustration this is this is good enough
yeah
okay
so so now we have a roughly a general
recipe to building you know various
kinds of non-interactive arguments
which is design again non-interactive
arguments with potentially different
properties
so you start with a appropriate sigma
protocol again appropriate depends on
your application then you construct a
cih hash function which is correlation
intractable for
again the appropriate battery relation
defined with respect to the sigma
protocol and then use some you know you
marry them together right so
i should say that even though we don't
care about zero knowledge in this talk
uh the previous uh transformation does
preserve zero knowledge and in fact this
was sort of the
one of the important motivations for
this line of work right
okay so let's talk about existence of uh
correlation interactable hash functions
so this is a very partial list there are
many other results using uh various
other assumptions like io and uh and so
on uh
but uh in terms of using lwe we we have
uh really nice uh you know uh results so
we can obtain ci hash for polynomial
size uh circuits so bad functions
described as polynomial size circuits um
and then uh there's also for the
purposes of this talk what is even more
relevant is the is the more recent work
of
justin alex and ron which
shows how to build cih for a particular
class of sparse relations which is this
efficiently verifiable product relations
so which is very useful in protocols
where you're doing pallet repetition
and
you can also build a
ci hash for some smaller classes using
uh sub-exponential ddh
okay
so
so i should mention that
you know while we are interested in this
talk in achieving uh succinct
non-interactive arguments using this
paradigm
this paradigm has been very successful
over the recent years for various
objectives perhaps one of the more
popular ones have been in building
non-interactive zero knowledge proofs
from new assumptions including uh you
know the breakthrough work on building
music from lwe right which was resolved
using uh this approach
and there have been many other uh
applications as well
so
the natural question is right that can
we now use this paradigm also for
building uh snarks
and we can again just look at that
recipe the general recipe that i
mentioned earlier and then just try to
tweak it in a natural way right so
instead of starting with an arbitrary
sigma protocol we should start with
a succinct sigma protocol uh
because
you know the the transformation doesn't
really compress right it just preserves
the the communication
and then you know the rest of the steps
should be hopefully be the same
okay so so that's the the starting point
so one very natural candidate you know
starting uh succinct interactive
protocol is for example killian right
it's not even just p and batch and pins
in fact a succinct argument for uh for
np right and we can uh we can ask
whether we can just apply this approach
to uh kilian
in fact if this could work it would not
only give us uh snags of p and batch and
p but
maybe even even all of np
so the sort of the main challenge uh
with this uh
with this approach is that uh killian uh
is an argument system right it's a
succinct uh argument system whereas the
the the cih uh you know line of work has
essentially you know it's essentially
works uh when you start with a
interactive protocol which is a proof
system a statistically sound proof
system okay there is perhaps one
exception to this which i haven't
mentioned here but this is the the main
this is the main story
so now we can ask okay is there any hope
to applying uh this approach to you know
argument systems
and you know you can at least
see some problem right in in trying to
do this so
uh first of all the known constructions
of ci hash you know supports parts
relations which essentially means uh you
know that
the starting protocol should be
statistically sound right because what
does this pass relations say it says
that for every alpha right there's only
few betas that can lead to accepting the
dhammas uh whereas if you think about
argument systems the problem is that for
every alpha and beta there could be an
accepting gamma it's just that it may be
hard to find right so it's not clear how
to apply this approach
to the setting of arguments at least in
general
so
now we can ask okay fine let's give up
on arguments maybe let's go to the
setting of
proofs again and
do we have good starting
interactive proofs that are succinct so
here we are very limited in what
you know good starting points
so one starting point is uh is you know
the well-known gkr protocol and indeed
uh you know which essentially gives you
bounded depth uh
you know such interactive proofs and
this is essentially what was used
in you know two recent works that i had
intentionally not mentioned earlier uh
basically these works by uh kennedy atal
and then more recently by uh giulia
which essentially
take a gkr and then show how you can
apply the
the ci hash framework on this protocol
to obtain snarks for bounded depth
computation
the only other really candidate that we
know a good starting point would be the
work of
rrr which gives you bounded space
computation but if you want
you know a protocol which is which is
for all of p and succinct
uh well
yeah that seems unlikely based on what
we know um
and if you think about batch np there
it's not like there are any fundamental
barriers that i'm aware of it's just
that we don't know how to build
succinct interactive proofs for batch np
for batch up we do know some protocols
at least with sublinear uh communication
okay so then the question
you know we are basically exhausting all
options one by one so now the the final
uh you know question remaining is that
can we apply this framework by somewhat
relaxing our soundness requirement maybe
we don't want we don't need full
statistical soundness maybe we can do
with something weaker that is still
sufficient
for this approach and that's essentially
what i'm going to not talk about so i'm
going to
give our definition
for the case of batch np so
okay so i'm going to define a notion of
interactive arguments for batch and p
which have two modes and
there will be statistical soundness in
some cases and not in the other cases
okay so that's the the general idea so
again so we have the scenario where we
have approver a verifier the prover
wants to prove that case statements are
true
and
in the normal mode
so there's a crs which can be either in
the normal mode
or it can be in a trapdoor mode and in
the trapdoor mode the crs can be
programmed on an index okay so this
index i can be from 1 to k
and the requirement is that if the crs
is in the trapped remote programmed at
index i
that
then any statement that the approver
will prove
add the ith index right so there you
will have statistical soundness
so if the statement is false the prov
the statement that the approver is
proving at that index i if it is false
it will be caught okay even even if the
prover is unbounded
do you really need the normal mode can
it be like the trapdoor mode with i
equals i don't know like sure i mean
yeah i mean i guess you can define it
that way
sorry there isn't really a qualitative
yeah yeah so in that sense uh you know
it's
the distribution yeah can be
can be nicer sorry yeah okay
and you know for most of you it should
be easy to see that this notion is
essentially inspired by somewhere
statistical binding uh commitments right
which is this notion of
hash functions commitments where
you have a succinct commitment of a
vector and you can still be statistical
binding at one or more location you know
the the commitment size or the hash size
grows with the number of indices where
you are statistical binding
so now let me just illustrate uh very
quickly why is this uh notion you know
useful why it can help get around this
issue of you know applying the ci hash
framework so the idea is fairly natural
uh you know if you want to prove uh
correlation in tractability you want to
start with something uh you want to
start with a proof which is
statistically sound right so here we can
rely on the structure of the batch np
you know this this language
if the statement overall batch is false
then it means that there is at least one
index i some x i which is false right so
we can you know program the crs at index
i now we have a
statistical soundness and now we can
actually apply the ci hash framework
right all we wanted is to you know start
with statistical soundness and this
allows you to uh to do that right
yeah
so the thing is that good so it is and
the thing is that or is easy in the
sense that in order there's already a
short witness right
uh i mean now you can ask okay
combinations of uh then then yeah that's
uh that's a whole different uh question
and there uh i mean we don't prove
anything in this work but uh i would
conjecture that some extension should be
should work it's just that again or on
its own it's not interesting unless you
want a zero knowledge property right
because in or there's already a short
witness you just maybe you want to hide
which of the you know yeah which of them
is true so yeah
yeah the extensions that are known yeah
so what about it so what we know they're
saying is that in the designated
verified setting there are some
extensions known from uh you know from
batch np to you know some uh
circuits
yeah monotone circuits and uh i believe
that the same should work here as well
what i was saying is this feels like it
really relies on the properties of that
this this yes but uh but again you can
use the ideas
okay
okay good so okay so now that we you
know we have moved past this issue of uh
you know what is the right starting
point so a starting point is going to be
dual mode or
somewhere statistically sound batch
arguments whatever you want to call them
so the first step will be now to build
these objects for all of np in the
interactive setting right
um once we have them again you can apply
the ci hash transformation uh for our
particular
scenario we will need ci hash from the
work of uh you know hlr so this is this
transformation is something i'm not
going to talk about
it works along expected lines it's just
that we need to use this particular ci
hash it just because of the design of
our interactive argument
system and then the second step is once
we have snots for batch and p
then i'll talk about a general
transformation to go from this object to
snox for p
okay
so actually in the presentation i'm
going to switch the order so i'm first
going to talk about the the general
transformation convince you that batch
np are useful for you know snarks for p
and then i'll talk about the
construction
okay so let's look at this
transformation of going from snox for
batch np to stocks for p and even this
transformation i'm going to simplify it
uh to the scenario where p is actually
bounded space
computations there are general uh you
know
general tricks using merkle trees
etcetera to go from
bounded space to
so okay so how would we try to use batch
np if i want to uh you know prove to you
actually uh correctness of some
polynomial time computation so here is a
very natural idea i look at uh you know
all the steps of the intermediate steps
of the computation the p computation so
let's say you know some t
steps are there right so i write down
all of these states of the turing
machine right so st1 to st some capital
t
and now i can create a batch of
statements so what is the batch of
statements it's saying that look i went
from the first state to the second state
you know this is a valid transformation
then from the second state to third
state this is the valid transformation
and so on and so forth right so now i
have a bunch of
statements
and i can try to use
a snog for batch np to prove the
correctness of this polynomial time
computation okay
so that's a very natural starting point
and
so again i'm i'm obviously omitting lots
of details here and i'll come to that in
a moment and now in terms of you know
arguing security i could hope to again
do the natural thing you know first i
will try to argue that the first step is
uh was actually correct by using the
soundness of
snark for batch np right then i will
argue that the the second step was
correct then i'll argue the third step
was correct and so on until i reach the
end and hopefully i have you know
established that the entire sequence of
trans you know computation was uh
correct so that's essentially the hope
what we would like to do this doesn't
quite work for uh you know
various uh natural reasons
so
the first thing we have to address is
that uh you know if you look at the size
of the
the number of
instances for this batch np language
well that's essentially capital t right
where t is the runtime of the turing
machine right and the problem is that uh
for batch np right the verifier must
read all the instances and if it reads t
instances well then the verifier is
already running in time and you know t
capital t which is something we don't
want
okay so so so so we need to solve the
problem of number of instances and the
way we are going to solve it is by using
basically uh ssb commitment with the
short
you know
local openings so basically we take all
of these states we you know commit to
them using ssb commitment and now my new
uh you know instances will essentially
be that uh
so i'm just going to prove that for
every
i right i i have two states sti and st i
plus one and their corresponding ssb
openings and uh i will prove that a the
openings are valid right so they they
are accepting and that the transition
from sti to sti plus one is also
valid
okay so now what are our new instances
for this batch np language well it's
basically just these indices right it's
basically the first instance is index
one the second instance is index you
know two and and so on essentially right
okay so now you know we have more
structure on this uh instances and now
what we actually will what i'm going to
show you later on is actually a snark
for a particular kind of batch npe
language which is what i call batch
index language so here there is one
circuit c that is fixed and the
instances are just these indices i
and in this case you know we will build
uh snarks for batch index where the
verification time you know is just uh
polylog t so there's no additive key
term or anything
yeah so can you actually extend this to
the setting of incrementally verifiable
computation
okay so this is the way to overcome the
issue of uh
the verify running time being
potentially linear in capital t so this
this is how we will uh avoid it this is
of course inherently computational and
you set it in the information setting we
know that we cannot
do it for p in proofs right and for you
for a batch and paid still open
yeah yeah so potentially there is such
information production which would rule
out
um
proofs for batch
that will rule out extending uh batch up
to batch np if such a transformation
could be made to work
uh which my question is
do we know if there is in the setting of
proofs uh
a similar transformation from batch np
to or to pr
this will give us a negative i feel yeah
a negative result for batch np okay
that's a good question i
don't know
this approach is inherently yeah this is
very computational yeah that's a good
question though yeah
okay so so that was the issue of
verification time which again like i
said i basically just defer to later
you know with a new problem statement
about stocks for batch index language so
now let's talk about uh soundness right
so how will we argue that this is sound
so again the natural idea here would be
that you know so our crs will contain
the ssb key the the key to the ssb
commitment right which we can program at
various indices and the natural idea
would be to you know program it at a
pair of consecutive indices at a time so
as to extract those states from the
commitment reason about uh valid
transition and then keep on progressing
further from basically from the start
till the end of the computation right
so initially i could start with the i
star and i star plus one for semi star
and then go from i star plus one to i
star plus two right and try to progress
so one thing that i have to be careful
about is that uh you know there's a con
i mean these uh these this is a sequence
of computations right these are not
independent computations this is the
same
you know incremental computation so i
have to make sure that i when i do this
switch from ssb key being programmed on
i star and i start plus 1 to i star plus
1 and i start plus 2
this
you know the the common value which is
this
what the adversary committed on i start
plus 1 doesn't quite
change right
and because if if it did
maybe i cannot argue anymore that the
start you know it's the same uh sequence
of transformations
okay so this is actually not a new
problem this has been studied before in
the designated verified setting if
you're familiar with that literature and
know about no signaling pcps and so on
then uh you know you know
the the the way to solve this problem in
our in our work we use this notion of no
signaling ssbs which is again very very
similar idea the the intuition is
essentially the same what it's saying is
that
you can consider a notion of ssb where
the key can be programmed on a bunch of
indices so let's say either s1 and in
the other experiment it can be
programmed on a bunch of indices two
sets of indices and what we want is that
the indices in the intersection right
the
when you apply the extractor in the
first case or in the second case the
values in the intersection don't quite
change
that's the
that's the requirement
why is it called no signaling you know
that's not my my name but it comes from
the literature on no signaling pcps i
guess presumably that's the
that's the reason for the name
yeah exactly i mean that that is
essentially yeah it's just uh yeah i
mean that's the construction what alex
is asking is that you know don't you get
this property very easily and indeed you
know
you can use the name or you can ignore
the
the formulation and just prove this
property in line which is essentially
this transformation you just take a ssb
and you know many copies of it and you
get this property essentially very
easily
confused these are two separate
independent experiments
so so either
right the commitment may be totally
different
that's fine i mean so what we are asking
for here is that uh
it's the same distribution regardless if
i give you a case
okay
okay so now that we have this now we can
actually do that you know proof of
soundness and now i'm using the the more
familiar technology of local global
consistency right so again the point was
that by using uh ssb extraction and the
soundness of batch uh
snarks for batch np we were arguing
about correctness of one step of this
computation at a time right so initially
we argued that uh you know the first
step is correct and then you know we
change the the crs and now we want to
argue that the the the next step is
correct and here now we are going to
rely upon the no signaling property to
basically say that you know the
extracted value corresponding to the
second state
it still uh you know basically leads to
you know is still consistent with the
starting point and it will need to
accept so you can now keep on
progressing uh sorry further and further
until the end and you will argue overall
soundness
so again the bottom line here is that uh
if you think about batch np there all
the instances are completely independent
right and uh
whereas in p the when when i when i
reduce p to batch and p the instances
are interval are related and therefore i
need to reason about uh you know all of
them together and
because the proof is small and the
soundness property of batch and you know
batch np allows me to only reason about
one small
you know portion of the computation at a
time i need to tie them together and
that's what this no signaling property
is uh giving me
okay and again this is very analogous to
what was done in the in the literature
on uh
you know on private delegation in fact
uh there is an alternative
transformation from the work of yael we
know than uh and rachel which uh
rachel or lisa originally yeah okay
sorry
uh yes um which basically gives uh you
know which which actually just uses no
signaling pcps to uh you know to go from
batch and p to p and one nice thing
about this alternative transformation is
that it basically gives you uh shows you
a way to go from batch np to
any subclass of np for which you have no
uh
pcgs
so for example you can get bounded space
and p also just generically from this
transformation whereas if you were to
try to obtain bounded space np from
the the transformation that i showed you
you will have to reason about it again
basically
and uh one point that i want to mention
is that essentially the main technical
barrier you know when you want to build
snots for uh you know any
any any class right the
the main technical barrier almost
inevitably turns out to be
finding a way to go from local to global
consistency and i'll revisit this point
towards the end of the talk
when did i start
you started at two
you can have a little bit uh
maybe four minutes after three
okay i'm going quite slow okay
all right
okay so now the next step is uh
you know okay so we we did the
transformation from batch and p2p and
now the remaining uh task is to build
smart for batch np and even there like i
mentioned i'm only going to focus on
building an interactive protocol
compressing it to a non-interactive
version is not something i'm going to
talk about okay
so the goal is to build dual mode
interactive batch arguments and the
recipe for this is very very simple and
very natural basically think of killian
except that now instead of uh you know
proving one statement i'm trying to
prove multiple statements so i will take
uh you know the witnesses for all of
these let's say capital t statements
okay
and i'm going to prepare pcps for all of
them
but now instead of committing them in
the in the way you commit to them in
killian here uh i'm going to actually
commit to them uh column wise okay so
again if you think about uh you know
let's fix some uh terminology
right so the number of instances is
capital t
okay the size of the pcp i don't really
care you know it's some some some
polynomial in in the witness size okay
and if you remember uh the efficiency
requirement for uh batch np is that uh i
am okay with paying communication
polynomial in the size of one witness
but i don't want it to be witnessed
times the number of instances right so
so if i commit to all of these pcps
column buys right then my total uh first
round message that i'm going to send is
essentially going to be
these ssb commitments which is
polynomial in the witness length
okay
and loggers make in in capital t which
is okay
okay so that's the first one message now
the verifier can send me pcb queries and
now the approver will uh basically open
uh you know the columns okay so imagine
the the pcb queries are essentially the
same for all the instances
so now i just go to those particular
columns and i just open them
okay so that's the starting point
now you know the verifier will you know
essentially
verify all the ssb uh openings and then
the the pcps right for uh for all the
instances so okay so here you can
already see um
okay so actually before getting into the
you know the issues with verification
time and so on and so forth let me just
say that if you if you buy the structure
of this protocol then proving security
is also going to be very natural if we
want to prove this dual mode security we
can switch the ssb key
you know to one which is uh binding at
one particular index and that will allow
me to basically be binding at one uh you
know entire row which will allow me to
extract that entire uh pcp out and then
i can argue soundness so that's not a
problem the main issue here is really uh
efficiency
okay so if you look at this uh
construction
what is the verification time here
actually well the verifier is actually
reading
you know omega t uh values right because
each of these uh columns itself is uh a
size uh capital t
right so therefore the verification time
is not
not uh what i want it's not polylog t
okay
so the idea here is that uh what we will
do is that instead of asking the
verifier to do this verification on its
own we will ask him to basically just
delegate this verification process to
the prover itself
okay so
so you can think of uh you know these uh
these uh columns right so you can first
of all you can use ssb with local
openings right
and now
i can look at basically uh you know
capital t verification uh processes
right and now i can just define this as
a new batch uh language right and i can
hope to run
another
snark for uh batch index language right
and then basically now the approver can
give this proof and hopefully this will
reduce the the verified time
okay
so so that's the idea right so what is
the so if we started with basically t
instances right now i'm asking the
prover to give me another snog right for
a batch index language how many
instances are there
well it's still capital t right because
i didn't really do anything as is right
the the verified needed to verify t
openings and tpcp you know right and i'm
still doing the same thing right so we
haven't really done anything right
ideally we would like to have some
saving in this step so that then we can
do some recursion
right okay so what i'm going to do now
is start grouping uh these uh you know
um these instances into
uh
fewer number of instances
to have some saving in the instance
length and then i can you know recurse
okay so
let me try to speed up through this a
little bit so first of all what i can do
is i can define a new uh relation where
instead of verifying uh you know one
instance i'm verifying two instances at
a time right and we can use the
structure of the instances here right so
the instances are just these indices
right one two three four so for instead
of one two i can just write
one and from that i can derive basically
you know one and two on my own right
this is this can just be part of the
verification algorithm and similarly for
the next one right so now just with this
simple uh utilization of the structure
of the instance i now have t by two
instance
okay
but
we're still not done mainly because the
verification time right is still
actually twice what it was uh you know
what it was in the single case right
because the problem is that we are
actually performing two verifications
right and if you just use standard pcps
what is going to happen is that the
verification algorithm will be at least
proportional to the size of the the
circuit right which is the circuit that
we started with so now when you do this
uh batching the verification time of the
new batch relation right is actually two
times capital c
simply because uh you know each of these
steps here involves basically verifying
performing two pcp verifications right
so now we have two times c and now you
can see that if you recurse it will
start blowing up and at the bottom level
of the recursion you will have t times
capital c
again no saving at all right
so basically the final trick is just to
use uh pcps with this offline online
property where the idea is that
the pcpa verifier can first use the the
circuit description to produce a queries
and a small state a compact state
and now there's a decision algorithm an
online decision algorithm which depends
on the instance and that succinct state
but and then outputs accept or reject
but uh this the running time of this
decision algorithm is just dependent on
the instance length not on the circuit
size okay
so now if you have such uh pcps then
it's you know the idea is fairly natural
what we will do is we will run this
query generation algorithm once and for
all and then just keep it outside the
recursion
right in the recursion this query
generation algorithm doesn't happen only
the decision algorithm shows up which is
fast and therefore now we don't have any
more blow up
good so so that's essentially you know
all uh
all i wanted to say about the
construction of snots for batch
for batch np
so this gives you batch index from batch
index you the simple tricks to get
general batch np and from there i
already showed you how to go from batch
and p2p okay
so
in terms of cryptographic assumptions
right why does the lw show up so it
shows up in two places
so we are using ssb commitments uh with
local openings those you can you can
actually build from variety of
assumptions so that's not really the
crucial lw part the crucial lwe part is
the ci hash function of uh alex justin
and ron which i didn't really touch upon
that one we only know from lw currently
and this is why this result is crucially
uh using lwe
io
i mean this particular transformation is
using uh
actually is there any version of uh
you know your result alex from io uh
uh
so it's a little complicated well first
of all io won't give you like ssb type
things right so you'll have to make an
additional assumption for that
but
then uh for just the correlation
attractability you should be able to do
it okay
okay so let me use the last
wait but ignoring this approach just
this
is snarks for pay with full adaptive
service for bio is that no i think that
isn't that known from our uh
version of our paper
from the i o for turing machine approach
okay
so let me now talk about some more
recent work that happened subsequent to
these works and some some open questions
so first we can ask the question about
assumptions again right what assumptions
do we really need to build these objects
i showed you that if you can build them
from lwe
but it's obviously natural to ask can we
build them from other assumptions
something other than lwe or
io um
so there are some results uh
that are known in this regard so first
of all even in the work prior to the
work that i presented we did show some
constructions of snarks for batch np
with very weak such thickness
not quite strong enough to obtain snarks
for p and there the assumptions we used
were basically a combination assumption
qr and sub exponential ddh and again
you know the exact combination is not
that important the main point is that
the you know we are basically beholden
to what kind of ci hash do we know and
then uh you know from what assumptions
do we know ci hash and then that
dictates basically what assumptions uh
we are using here uh and then subsequent
to the work that i presented uh uh there
was a work by uh lititol which uh you
know did give better efficiency so snots
uh uh for batch and pnp with sublinear
signals again not poly log but sublinear
uh succinctness uh from the same
assumptions qr and sub exponential dps
yeah so weak is that there we actually
have like linear in the k term but it's
not like k times c it's like k plus
something
so
in terms of if you want to follow this
particular approach of using ci hash to
build slogs then you know one natural
pressure point is uh you know what kind
of assumptions can you build ci hash
from and uh you know the current
technique seems to
rely upon these strong tools uh
compression compression tools like fhe
or trap door hash etc and you know it's
not we don't know uh to what extent are
these techniques uh necessary
so that's a question of independent
interest even if you don't care about
snots
per se because you know
any any progress on this phone would
also have progress would also lead to
progress on music from other assumptions
and
and the many applications of ci hash
okay uh another question you can ask is
well must we uci hash or can we use this
fiat chameleon plus ci hash approach all
together uh that would be great and
there is in in fact uh you know really
cool uh work by uh
by brent and david uh uh recently which
shows how you can get uh snarks for
batch np and p from uh
typo here yeah from bilinear maps
one really cool part of this is that it
doesn't use pcps at all right
i think the only caveat slide caviar
that i know of is that the crs size can
be is sublinear rather than polylog but
it doesn't show in the verification time
because the verifier doesn't need to
read the entire crs only the prover
reads the the long crs okay
so it doesn't use even linear pc
yeah so this is i mean that the cool
thing about it is it's a very natural
you know it's uh
uh
you can think of it as essentially
taking the non-zk version of gos and
batching it and then uh yeah batching it
basically yeah so both the commitments
uh as you know the gate by gate
commitments and then also the proofs the
batch group for
so you can ask the question whether it's
possible to mimic or you know
somehow adapt their approach to lwe so
as to avoid the use of pcps altogether
that's a that's a great open question
okay a couple of words about efficiency
so you can ask the question can we build
uh these snots for these particular
subclasses that i talked about in
particular batch np with better
communication rate so the the solution
that i i presented it uh there the size
of the proof is essentially poly
log in k comma sorry poly in law k comma
w right so it can right whereas you
could hope for something much much
better which is essentially just the
size of a single witness plus some
additive terms right
that's not achieved by our solution
and the cool thing about achieving such
a nice rate is that it naturally leads
to many nice applications because you
can start composing these groups you can
start uh you know proving things about
proofs and and so on so you can do for
example uh incrementally verifiable
computation uh which uh the question
that stefan was asking and there is a
recent uh
cool work that i'm aware of uh by
richard yail and vinod which does give a
solution to this problem uh i think
assuming lwe
oh okay yeah
okay
cool uh okay i'm going to skip this uh
this point okay so maybe i'll take two
more minutes is that okay yeah yeah okay
so i i think perhaps the most
interesting uh open question is
obviously can we find a way to
circumvent uh gentry bricks right okay
so a word about gender wix first of all
what does the statement actually say
what does their impossibility say so it
basically says that
you cannot have a you cannot build
snarks for np
where the proof of soundness is
is black box okay so it makes black box
use of the adversary
second soundness is adaptive meaning
that
the adversary chooses the instance after
looking at the crs
so these are the two main requirements
uh the third one is just a technical
thing so what i mean by this l greater
than y is that basically it requires
that the language is harder to decide
than uh
you know the the assumption basically so
in other words the the reduction cannot
decide the language right that's uh
that's a technical department in the uh
okay
so so there are these uh ways of you
know so basically these uh restrictions
also obviously potentially uh pose a way
to you know potentially pose a path to
try to circumvent this lower bound uh
black box reductions uh you know we
don't know of many examples of non-black
box reductions so perhaps that is a
harder route perhaps the most tempting
you know
path is to try to
achieve non-adaptive soundness right so
what do we know about
this again even here the main challenge
turns out to be this local to global
consistency it would seem that in the
non-adaptive setting perhaps this is not
so much of a challenge but uh you know
it it still shows up we still don't know
how to overcome this again the the proof
techniques always do this thing of
arguing correctness of sub computations
and tying them together and we only know
how to make this work for uh
various subclasses uh but not for uh all
of np
of course is this question any different
from that like are you separating this
question from the question of whether
you can build no signaling pct not
really i mean
is this is this question any different
from construction of no signaling tcps
computational signaling
tcps um
but you're you're asking the question of
go beyond uh
no signaling pcps right
i mean but we don't know of any barrier
to computational signaling pcbs right
that we can't build them for is there
any lower bound computational no single
increase fees even a stronger object
yeah so they can only exist for i don't
know
no but do we have any lower bounds there
that we can't no signaling tcp with
communication l can only be for
languages the side of one time two to
the l
something like that
okay and then you know the perhaps the
the natural question is what about i o
right can we use i o to build
non-adaptive
snarks for np and indeed we know of
a result right so we know there's a high
waters construction which gives you
stocks for np
you know there's a large crs involved
there let's ignore that caveat uh and
now you know you can instantiate that uh
construction with let's say gls and you
get uh snarks for non-adaptive snacks
for np with the corresponding
assumptions okay so
one last slide i'll just mention you
know one caveat of this uh of this
result right is that uh if you actually
take a closer look at what happens when
you instantiate the
uh
the high waters construction with the
jls or in fact any other
any other i o constructions what would
happen is that in some sense it bypasses
gentry wicks
irrespective of the fact that the
soundness is non-adaptive
it's because what happens is that the
the order the the hardness requirement
flips
generic says that
the reduction should not be able to
decide the language right but when you
instantiate io because of the i o input
length barrier you know which is that
the the reduction always seems to incur
exponential loss in the input length
what happens is that you end up
requiring that the assumption
is actually harder than the language in
other words the reduction can actually
decide the language okay so this sort of
happens so you can ask a question if you
know if this can be circumvented
essentially
so i i won't mention too much but there
is some progress on this for subclasses
of np even subclass of nb intersection
conf it's uh you know
there are several uh caveats to this
result but there's some progress on this
front which i can talk about offline if
somebody is interested
if you relax
told snarks for np where
the proof length is
input size as opposed to
weakness size
full succinctness what do we have any
barriers
close the question again if the if the
snare it's a proof length is the instant
size
uh not witness size
you allow the proof size to grow with
the instant size
do we know anything about that
it's a good time to leave this to the
discussion of the world
we come in at 3 30. thank you